Janet Jackson pays tribute to her big
bro Michael on his birthday Taylor Swift
pays tribute to Aretha Franklin and
Simon Cowell is brought to tears on a GT
happy birthday to the King of Pop MJ
would have turned 60 today and fans are
honoring him all over the world let's
his sister Janet taking us back with the
ultimate video shoot yes that is Janet
channeling model Iman from Michaels
remember the time video
only this time King Bach and blame it on
quays alter ego TT are the ones dancing
for this Queen
[Music]
hey Quay is next level working with the
legend on her first social media video
ever
they had me rolling on that one but as
you pay tribute to one music legend on
his birthday we say farewell to another
mr. Reetha Franklin rethus funeral is on
Friday in Detroit and last night at her
concert in the same city Taylor Swift
paid her respects to the Queen of Soul I
would like
we could have a moment of silence so
that every single one of us could
reflect on our love and respect for her
and everything that she did in her life
Taylor led the Detroit crowd in a moment
of silence about 45 minutes into the
show and while Taylor isn't expected at
Friday's funeral ariana grande is et has
learned to read this family was so
touched by Ari's performance on The
Tonight Show they asked her to be part
of the funeral hey you know speaking of
Ariana the girl's gone and got another
tattoo and know this isn't another
tribute to Pete this time it's for
herself the 26 year old debuted the new
ink on her Instagram story
it's a giant arm tat of anime character
Chihiro
from the movie spirited away now the
size of the tattoo has fans shook but
ariana shared the special significance
of it quote during her adventure in the
spirit world she matures from an easily
scared girl with a childlike personality
to match her age to a hard-working
responsible and brave young girl who has
learned to put her fears aside for those
she cares for no doubt Ari is drawing
from her own growth over the last year
between the Manchester bombing her
engagement to Pete Davidson and her
latest album sweetener by the way her
latest ink was done by Mira Mariah the
same tattoo artist who gave Ari that
bumblebee tat she got back in May to
honor the victims of the Manchester
attack meanwhile last night's episode of
America's Got Talent was honestly one of
the most emotional ever everybody was
losing it especially after watching
Simon's golden buzzer Michael Ketterer
even the show's toughest judge was moved
to tears
[Music]
that's dad you know I can't imagine what
you darlings the fact that you were on
this show and and you really need this
you're really really special diet cry
too much
you've just an incredible person an
incredible human being to do what you've
done taking on board adopting all these
kids and giving them life and then
you'll do your voice sings such truth
and honesty I was trying to hold it to
go yeah yeah I was actually yeah because
that normally doesn't happen to me but
there's something about Michael and now
I've got to know him and what it means
to him and then you reminded you know
with the tape and everything and because
I'm a dad as well it was yeah what was
it about it what is it about Michaels
story that kind of you connected with
the most what gotcha
it says sincerity kindness you know and
what he started to change those kids
life and then he puts it all out on the
line you know tonight and I know and I I
really fell for him you know he's a
really really special person
we're in emotional right let's talk
about the end there I mean I don't think
I've ever seen Simon that emotional
before not on television at least
they're taken by surprise no because I
believe what I've gotten a note Simon
personally over the last couple of years
and he is and I don't think people know
that what kind of a human being and what
kind of a father he is and what kind of
a friend he is and he's the biggest it
was also an emotional night for Mel B
she skipped the red carpet after
revealing this week she's entering rehab
for PTSD but for a GT family showed
their support for her decision and we
have that video and my interviews with
them for you guys now
all right guys make sure you come back
tomorrow because I have a special I mean
special surprise and a mamrie not
involved the Internet's new boyfriend
that's all insane I'll see you guys then
[Music]